hi everyone this is a video I've been
wanting to make since numberphile
started really because when you watch
football or soccer if that's what you
want to call up on the TV I'm always
amazed by the number of statistics and
numbers they're able to throw at you
during the game how do they do that
who's recording it so what I've done is
spent a couple of days at a company
called Opta who collect statistics from
various sports including soccer now in
this film I want to give you some idea
just how much information they collect
for every kick every header every missed
kick everything that happens on the
field during a game of soccer to do this
I've chosen just one kick as an example
and I thought seeing were choosing one
we should make it a special one so the
one we're doing is a kick by a guy
called Andres Iniesta in the 2010 World
Cup final and it was the kick that won
the game it was the scoring of the
winning goal in a one military against
Holland
now unfortunately due to copyright law I
can't show you the goal but it kind of
looks something like this just like
being there wasn't it but to a
statistics expert especially one from
copter the goal looks more like this so
enough from me here's Sam talking you
through the anatomy from a numbers
perspective of the goal that won the
last World Cup final for me I obviously
see it as well and I enjoy it but we
when we collect the data I also see it
as a not just numbers but a set of data
basically and this is the details of
every shot in that World Cup final so
that was all the shots in the game and
we're gonna look at just in detail about
Andres Iniesta throughout the winning
goal what the only goal the key stat the
key number for for us in this case it's
number 16 just completely random but for
us that's what a goal is that's if it's
an event 16 and we know it's a goal 16
is the magic number in football for an
OPS a football 16 very important when
you're walking around the street and you
see that number 16 on a house do you
think go do I think oh yeah and then
you've got number 1 is pass for me so
that's the one I see all the time so
yeah there's
you do come to think about when you're
watching a game you'll think about it in
the way the guys collect it and the way
that looks in the database which is a
mixed blessing so 13 is a Miss so if you
get it off target
who else is there a stop where 3 is a
dribble it's quite quite a fun one of
the more exciting things that can happen
so we know it's a goal we know it's
number 16 we can see when it happened in
the fourth period so that's the second
period of extra time the fourth sort of
overall period of the game when it
happens towards the end we know this is
his ID so I mean I know this is Andres
Iniesta 1 2 2 3 7 and the team that took
the shot obviously he was Spain so I
don't come one in some things that we
collected there's obviously whether it
was a good thing I completed or not
obviously with a goal we know it was
completed so it's a fun one most crucial
bit of information besides the fact that
was a goal is where it happened so these
are our coordinates for where it
happened on the pitch I can kind of show
you what not a 962 point 3 looks like
yeah really terrible this is why I do
maths no dear it's already gone wrong
and the six-yard box the goal is
probably about about here just gonna go
about here about knowing goes down to
about there these two points where he
tells me is over here this is 50 in the
middle so I know sixty two point three
is somewhere out here there's an
authentic recreation area yes I'll do
him with one little strand of hair
because that's about all he's got
so we've got that tells us something
about it but there's obviously a lot
more that happened as to why it was a
goal so no I would say so here we've got
sort of the sub aspect of the shot so my
yesterday - I can see the goal where I
went and the goal of y&z coordinates so
these are the goals so he stuck it about
here he stuck at the other side of the
goal and he went it went
not very high off the ground so probably
stuck it around about here we had before
that he took the shot there we now know
when pretty much in the bottom corner
not quite I tucked him but certainly to
the side of the keeper so I know it was
assisted and that it was an intentional
assist I know it went loads of the
keepers left which is make sense given
that he shot it from over here and we
know it ended up over here when with one
bounce hit it with his right foot hit it
on the volley and it
came from a counter-attack and I also
know that they keep the touch the ball
well I think as memory serves as a small
touch for us to kallenberg so that's the
anatomy of the goal this is kind of
that's all the information we collect
about it there are different different
shots different goals will have
different bits of information but that's
what we know about this shot so we can
then use that we can put all the
information in see you know how likely
was it that any ester would have scored
that goal goal that ended up winning the
World Cup now at this point I guess a
lot of you would like to see a bit more
about how the numbers are collected how
they harvest the statistics during the
game and I actually spent an entire
match day at ophtho I was able to watch
them during the games how they do it how
they interact with the commentators on
TV that's going to be in an upcoming
video but for now I thought I'd hear a
bit more from Sam about what he does
with the statistics after the game and
maybe a bit more about that andres
iniesta go to take example we go back to
the Iniesta one the model that we've
developed says ok we that chance and was
actually a really good chance for it as
they go is about 30% chance of being a
goal before we know anything about where
he even put it just to get the ball in
that good a position off a
counter-attack is a you know very good
chance of scoring 30% or zoom on don't
sound like that much but an average
shots probably around 8 to 10 percent so
this is this is a really good chance but
if we changed a few things if we moved
him if we took the shot back to here you
know it's the edge of the 18-yard box
and the shot was here it goes from maybe
30% here down to about I don't know 12
percent or so it drops to about there
equally if we if we brought the shot
inside so he's got the full range of the
goal to choose from go stand 30 percent
but now goes my cups about as high as 50
percent but I've developed a model which
takes into account all these kinds of
factors about what we know about the
shots because we've got such a huge
backlog of shots and details of them
absolutely more so I think you look at
things in a different way you think
about what what players are doing and
where they're doing it
and what what does that lead to and you
still enjoy it and you still watch the
game and it's still exciting and when
there's a great goal great save you
still have the same reflex reactions to
everything of excitement but you just
think about the game in a slightly
different way but I think for me it's
more fun I think it's better but you
know personal taste I guess I think the
Holy Grail is its kind of football
analytics and and you know what I'm
doing and what a lot of other people are
doing is I think you want to get to one
number that broadly encapsulates that
player and that players value or at
least on pitch value there are gonna be
other things age and contract which
always the affect their value to it
opposing team but purely on what they do
kind of value like you know baseball has
Wins Above Replacement and I think
that's kind of where I'm trying to take
it I think probably other people are
trying to do the same thing yeah pretty
much I mean I didn't want to say in the
interview but I if they just gave me
access to the database that I've been
pretty happy with that they didn't need
to pay me but they did they seem to want
to do that so that works for me
so thanks to the guys from Opta and a
reminder we'll have another video soon
where we go behind the scenes on
matchday which is far more exciting but
for now thank you for watching and some
more of the details about the statistics
can be found on the blog